ohio state pass rusher chase young will
not be working out at the scouting damn
i but i feel like i know no it's not
damn it's if he tears his acl i know i
know you're right i feel like there's
less of an effort by people in the media
to shame these guys than there used to
be there was a time and i don't know
maybe it's different when it's not a
quarterback who chooses to not work out
but because we want to be entertained
right what's the purpose of having these
prime time workouts if guys aren't going
to work out yeah but i i
i have been a firm proponent of guys
especially at the top of the draft like
what are you doing what's the point
right hayes in the barn yeah go watch my
film exactly watch my film and draft me
or don't draft me let one of your
competitors draft me it's up to you so i
got no problem with chase i got no
problem with the strategic decision not
to work out the guys who need to work
out are the guys who are in that scrum
trying to get drafted in around three
four five that you know and they know
who they are in their champions the good
agents they know who they are the guys
at the top
i am fully in support of them not doing
anything and i know that runs against
the idea that they're trying to make the
combine into this prime time big time tv
event you know i love coming here to
indianapolis can i accept it within the
next few years it's going to be in la
that's part of making it bigger and
bigger and bigger right and when guys
choose not to work out there are people
who get upset i don't i'm fine with it
especially when it's a chase young
because he has
everything to lose and nothing to gain
by working out at the combat right i
mean really has nowhere to go but down
so i mean i get that and you know i
think you're right i think the media and
people like us have laid off these guys
for not working out certainly compared
to the past because i think everybody
realizes hey this is a business and it's
about maximizing what you can get and
all those type of things am i
disappointed as a fan definitely i mean
i want to see chase young i mean chase
young is a super freak and i mean that
respectively i mean the way he looks
like he's a miles garage debbie on
clowney a guy that could do things in a
workout where we'd go holy crap are you
kidding me he's that big and ran that
fast you know that's what we said when
we saw miles garrett run right or gideon
county remember him and his personal
workout jump over all the bags and the
coaches like i've never had a player
jump over that many bags so that's
that's what we're gonna miss but we'll
see that during his pro day and you
never know where the player's at this
point in time right anyways right maybe
he banged up a pulled a quad muscle a
little bit maybe he doesn't feel like
he's a hundred percent but either way i
got no no issue with the decision at all
the other side of this coin is coined
too at some point at some point if
you're chase young right or whoever the
chase young is in any given year as this
becomes a larger and larger event and if
and when they ever start charging
admission to fill up a stadium and
you're performing out in front of all
those people it's there's a point where
it's no longer a job interview i mean
this is the only job interview where the
employer makes money off of the
interview because it's true at some
point the players have to say i want
something or i'm not going to do it
yeah i like how much money would it take
to get chase young if you were chase
young's agent yeah brother right father
500 000 i mean it was 250 it would take
something significant like that right
i'm sure i'll show up because
because if you go to the dog and pony
show until your point will you say and
kind of lay an egg or mess it mess a few
things up or tear an acl right you're
definitely costing yourself more than a
few hundred thousand dollars so i i
understand what you're saying there but
also too you know these are young kids
who want to make their first you know i
know but they want them this system
exploits it does they're young they're
full of testosterone yeah i think
they're never going to get hurt they're
good they're competitive that's always
here they're good soldiers competitors
right yeah they're good soldiers they
want to please the coaches the people
they're going to see in this next of
their professional baloney i get you but
it's easy for us just telling you well
i'm just telling you as a player that's
how you think i know and that's how we'd
both think if we were 21 yeah exactly
right but given the benefit of age and
time and wisdom or at least some
semblance of it we can say don't do it
screw you don't do me you yeah that's
right exactly
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports